[Music]
hello, how are you, sal y jaramillo greets you
with their briefing for today, Monday
, August 30, and it already weakened at
dawn on Monday to a
tropical storm after being a
category 4 hurricane and making landfall on Sunday on
the coast of  Louisiana affirmed and sent
the Nevada Force One rescue team
for assistance 28
national teams were called to assist
in the affected area 35 firefighters from the
valley were also sent and will
remain there as long as necessary
this morning a pedestrian died on and without
exaggeration here  we can see the
scene this morning at 4 this crossing is
still closed the authorities
advise taking alternate routes the pedestrian
was taken to the hospital but did not
survive
the clark county school district
reported more than 100,000 300
positive cases since july almost 600 of these
cases come from elementary schools
where students are not eligible
for the vaccine in March of this year
physio  began to study the effectiveness
of its vaccine in children from 6 months
to 11 years if it were to be approved
then they will do so under
urgent authorization for
minors from 5 to 11
possibly between September and October they
could continue with a
emergency order for minors
from 6 months
and finally students
this calf returned to
face-to-face classes this morning if they are
enrolling around 30 to 50 thousand
students each year from
all parts of the country despite the fact that today
is the first  day of classes young people
can still register the deadline is
September 5 also if it is on a
holiday since it celebrates its 50th anniversary
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a hot and sunny day
today with temperatures reaching 107
degrees  However, the temperatures will drop
tomorrow and
some clouds will appear in the valley. We will have
chances of rain and the
temperatures will  ras will remain
below three digits nice day you salute them
lighten medium and this was their brief
informative of ignis now in spanish
nadal
[Music]